thousands of people have been evacuated
homes and livelihoods destroyed tourist
holidays canceled and almost a week
since they began the wildfires on the
island of Rhodes rage on
it's estimated that 10 of the Island's
land area has been ravaged with
firefighters and aircraft working Round
the Clock
for one plane and its crew fighting
another fire on the island of Evia near
Athens tragedy upon tragedy as the pilot
loses control
[Music]
for weeks now wildfires have devastated
large swathes of Island and Mainland
Greece prime minister kiriakos
mitsotakis left no room for doubt about
the cause
let me State the obvious that in the
face of what is happening to the entire
planet especially the Mediterranean
which is a hot spot for climate change
there is no magic defense if there was
obviously we would have implemented it
the prime minister's words backed up by
the assessment of international
climatologists in a study by World
weather attribution it says current heat
wave conditions in China the United
States and southern Europe are
contributing to the hottest period on
Earth since the beginning of human
civilization conditions virtually
impossible they say without the buildup
of man-made global warming we don't
believe it all the islands burn we lost
our Island our beautiful island we don't
have anything now
really we don't have anything we don't
know what to do
and Greece is not alone Italy is burning
two here fires threaten to engulf the
airport in Palermo Sicily while storm
conditions have left a scene described
as apocalyptic in Milan
Jonah Hall Al Jazeera
foreign